que responsa fechar esse evento tão
brilhante
aprendi muito hoje e minha filha na área
está aqui na primeira fila e eu me
lembro que um dia há muitos anos atrás
eu me peguei fazendo com o meu filho
mais velho o ícaro que hoje é um homem
que naquela época era um menininho de 8
9 e 10 anos
aquela pergunta tola que nós adultos que
vamos fazer para todas as crianças
você quer ser quando crescer quero
na época não tinha ainda o técnico tinha
o teto mas ele com aqueles olhos verdes
de olhou estava na praia e olhou para o
horizonte
o fundo e disse pai eu quero ser
jornalista
eu fiquei entre a decepção e orgulho e
pergunta então pra ele vir mais por que
você quer ser jornalista
aí fez um ar ainda mais introspectivo
olhou de novo horizonte disse eu quero
ser jornalista para mudar o mundo
eu disse poxa vida agora complicou ea na
área que está aqui mais novinha levantou
a mão e dispara eu também quero ser
jornalista
e aí eu perguntei na época uma menininha
assim você quer ser jornalista também
para mudar o mundo
aí ela disse não não tem nada disso
eu quero ser jornalista ficar bem famosa
parecer todo dia no jornal nacional
e aí eu fiquei pensando naquelas duas
respostas na sua inocência e pensando
como aquilo talvez fizesse algum sentido
naquilo que leva muita gente nesses duas
razões que leva muita gente ao
jornalismo é preciso ter como ícaro um
monte de um bocado uma boa porção
generosa de idealismo um idealismo uma
necessidade talvez de interferir na
realidade de ajudar a transformar essa
realidade mas a gente percebe logo sendo
com poucos dias de trabalho que a gente
não vai mudar o mundo mas sem idealismo
ninguém abraça o jornalismo como queria
a nada
muita gente acredita que existe um certo
glamour
nesse ofício muita gente acredita que
vai ficar famoso vai conhecer gente
importante vai ser celebridade
a gente aprende também rapidinho que
isso é uma ilusão e ainda bem que a
gente aprende que é uma ilusão mas muita
gente embarca no jornalismo por um
motivo ou por outro por idealismo ou por
achar que vai ficar sua voz
no meu caso eu confesso a vocês que não
tinha a mínima idéia de que este jornal
está no dia jamais passou pela minha
cabeça desde muito pequeno eu fui
apaixonado pelo mundo dos livros eu fui
apaixonado pela palavra
se você me perguntar em qual é a minha
lembrança mais remota de infância vai
ser a de um inimigo hugo branquinho
magrela de óculos de fundo de garrafa
deitado no chão do alpendre da nossa
casa locais
lendo um dicionário doha ao z era minha
diversão como criança era compreender e
conhecer novas palavras conhecer o
significado
de novas palavras brincar com elas então
de alguma maneira eu sabia que de uma
forma ou de outra
eu ia viver da palavra pela palavra para
a palavra mas não sabia ainda que é o
jornalismo e como colecionador de
palavras
fui guardando aquele repertório a
sonoridade mas a vida foi me levando
para outros caminhos bem distantes disso
eu me lembro que quando terminei o
ensino fundamental e foi passar o ensino
médio era de uma família de classe média
e classe média baixa e as escolas de
segundo grau ensino médio eram muito
caras
então tenho que fazer uma opção e foi
estudar na escola técnica porque é de
graça e na escola técnica
quando eu vi a lista de cursos antiga
escola técnica
a lista de escuta e cursos olhei nada me
identifiquei ali nada daquilo mecânica
eletrotécnica telecomunicações
edificações estradas
eu olhei pedir socorro a psicóloga da
escola que fez o teste vocacional e me
disse olha
de uma coisa tenho certeza você não
nasceu para trabalhar em escritório
você não nasceu para trabalhar dentro de
uma sala de ar de com ar refrigerado seu
lugar na rua e aí olhei lá aquela lista
de cursos e na falta de outras opções da
opção escolhida estradas
bem foi um dos maiores erros da minha
vida fiz quatro anos de escola técnica e
trabalhei dois longos dias como técnico
de estradas foram os dois piores dias da
minha vida
larguei meu emprego cheguei em casa era
um emprego numa barragem da construção
de um açude em uma estrada em tianguá
voltei pra casa com a mochila dois dias
depois na mãe ficou furiosa e eu disse
pra ela vai descobrir que eu nem a minha
área não é essa
e ela disse então o que você vai fazer
eu descobri que eu quero fazer filosofia
minha mãe quase ter um colapso nervoso
fiz vestibular da filosofia passei os
dois anos de filosofia mas havia uma
inquietação larguei a faculdade
minha mãe adorou notícia e aí meu filho
agora você vai fazer o que eu disse
estou muito determinado e o que eu disse
quase a matou do coração
eu disse vou fazer letras pela minha
paixão pela literatura quando entrei na
faculdade de letras era apenas dramática
gramática gramática gramática
porém fora abandonei a faculdade
minha mãe que festejou e eu passei um
tempo na minha vida sem saber o que
fazer
fiquei parado e comecei a amigos algumas
vocês terem idéia eu fui técnico de
raio-x fazia biografia não sei se vocês
lembram
naquela época pra qualquer exame
admissional de emprego de escola você
tinha que levar a biografia pois bem
pois e técnico de raio-x fazendo é a
biografia depois fui balconista de uma
loja de autopeças de peças de
motocicleta
trabalhei há algum tempo ainda
procurando ainda tateando enfrentar a
muralha num trailer na avenida bezerra
de menezes com meu irmão
falamos o trailer
depois eu o tinha passado já pela temple
grafia tá lá o preço do litro
depois eu fui dar aula peguei aquela
aqueles cursos que eu tinha feito de
letras e filosofia inacabado conseguir
um emprego de professor em colégios da
periferia de fortaleza e estava com o
professor achando que eu tenho que
recuperar alguma daquelas duas
faculdades e ser professor
o salário do professor vocês sabem não
era nada animador
um amigo meu disse ter uma vaga num
jornal da cidade para revisor hoje em
dia infelizmente não existe mais essa
figura do revisor é aquele cara que pega
o texto do jornalista corrigir e manda
publicar leva para a gráfica gráfico bem
no dia que eu entrei nesse jornal
eu descobri o que é que o time teria que
fazer a minha vida toda eu não tinha
ainda conhecimento não tinha ciência do
que era que está me aguardando
na sala da revisão não tinha telefone
a revisão se concentrar se e aí eu
precisei fazer um telefonema e fui da
redação quando eu abri a porta da
redação parecia que tinha aberto assim a
porta do paraíso caminho ainda no tempo
da máquina de escrever tatá que eles
dezenas quase centena de jornalistas
todos batem nos atender o telefone
conversando alto disse que tava no chão
maravilhosa como é que sai o jornal isso
aqui e aí eu me apaixonei perdidamente
pelo jornalismo foi fazer de novo
vestibular já estava perto dos 30 anos
foi fazer vestibular e foi reinventar a
minha vida
naquele momento eu comecei um novo
momento e um novo processo novo no
instante da minha vida
mesmo com muito tesão com muita paixão
mas tinha alguma coisa ali que deixava e
me deixava sempre inquieto a minha
inquietação presente sempre aumentando a
pressão do tempo
a atração do espaço não satisfaziam
tenho que apurar uma matéria da forma
mais rápida possível escrever no menor
espaço possível de de página de jornal e
aí um dia na redação um colega que tinha
saído para fazer uma pauta burocrática
sobre o serviço de saneamento da cidade
chegou com a manchete do dia tinham sido
descobertas no bairro jacarecanga
centenas de corpos humanos
milhares de corpos humanos e um jornal
passou três dias para descobrir o que
era aquilo
precisou o professor geraldo nobre
história nos dá um puxão de orelha e
femininos
quanta ignorância não sabe não sabe que
foi isso de ser vítimas da ditadura no
cemitério clandestino eo professor geral
nove meninos
essas são as vítimas da terrível
epidemia de varíola que matou um quinto
da população de fortaleza
na virada do século 19 o século 20 como
vocês não sabem disso
e aquela pergunta do professor geraldo
nobre ficou é quando na minha cabeça
como nós nós sabemos disso
como kaká um fato que aconteceu a pouco
mais de 100 anos foi apagado na nossa
memória coletiva e aí eu disse aí está
uma história pedindo para ser contada e
foi quando eu resolvi escrever o meu
primeiro livro que era a história de
rodolfo teófilo
o sanitarista que enfrentou sozinho
outra o poder estabelecido na época essa
epidemia e quatro anos um trabalho de
convencimento da população conseguiu
erradicar a varíola e aí eu descobri que
eu precisava mais uma vez começar do
zero passar a régua e fazer um salto
ousado largar o emprego da redação
largar meu emprego naquele momento já
estava inclusive um cargo de chefia e
começar a do zero de novo
ora como um autor de livros meus amigos
da redação
ele assegurou que seu evento escrever
livros num país de analfabetos mas eu
tomei pra mim aquele desafio e depois
começaram a surgir outros livros
a biografia do castelo porque mais uma
vez eu queria descobrir eu que nasci em
63 antes do golpe
queria entender como aquele golpe e se
tornou possível como foi aqui onde era o
que surgiu esse castelo quem é esse
homem e aí fiz a biografia do castelo
saiu em 2004 os 40 anos do golpe castelo
a marcha para a ditadura
depois veio a biografia de josé de
alencar o inimigo do rei que me deu o
primeiro chute depois do alencar
inclusive se inscrevia grafia de alencar
é porque alguma espécie de ajuste de
contas
eu na minha juventude da minha
adolescência tinha sido torturada pelas
professoras que me empurravam josé de
alencar e onde haja josé de alencar com
todas as minhas forças e aprendi que
josé alencar não é nada daquilo que a
escola ensina que alencar era um sujeito
sarcástico irreverente polêmico e é esse
alencar que está no inimigo do rei
depois veio esse caso de amor e ódio com
essa mulher é terrível é realmente
maravilhosa
maysa que acabou depois é ver o vende os
direitos para uma minissérie
depois de marisa vê o padre cícero e
mais uma vez era uma certa um certo
ajuste de contas eu menino e fortaleza
de costas pro sertão
durante toda a minha vida durante toda a
minha adolescência padres isso pra mim
era simplesmente o signo da ignorância e
da cidade do fanatismo religioso
passei dez anos estudando essa criatura
e hoje compreendo e respeito muito a fé
do goleiro eu sou magnético
descobri que a fé do goleiro é
transgressora porque ela não se submete
a assepsia do rio ela não submete aos
caros da igreja oficial parece ser o foi
o que me possibilitou a partir de então
a viver única e exclusivamente dos
livros que eu escrevo e finalmente
produzir a biografia de getúlio em três
volumes que o cujo volume da trilogia
saiu agora há pouco mais de um mês e
está há cinco semanas a sorte minha na
lista dos do topo da lista dos mais
vendidos em todo o brasil
hoje eu vivo
hoje eu vivo dos meus livros mas
continuo sendo essencialmente um
repórter
continuo sendo essencialmente o
jornalista faz reportagens históricas
não mais pressionado agora pelo tempo
nem pelo espaço
mas o que cada um desses personagens
inclusive me ensinou só isso daria uma
palestra sobre cada uma
mas eu descobri que eles foram pessoas
todos eles sem exceção que souberam se
reinventar em algum momento de sua vida
começaram do zero em algum instante e
superar uma dificuldade inicial e deram
a volta por cima e se tornaram que são
conhecidos são biografado fez exatamente
isso que a gente não pode achar que está
passando o tempo para se reinventar a
nossa vida tem que ser desta
dessa forma quem construiu as situações
objetivas e ela nervosa a tal ponto e
que portanto nós temos que seguir
adiante não
sempre é tempo de recomeçar à risca a
apostar alto é o porteiro do meu prédio
dia 10
algum tempo atrás e perguntou se era
brincar que se houve mesmo
e olhei pra ele josé el escrevo livros
aí ele olhou pra mim assim com a cara de
desolação e disse o senhor vive disso
eu disse essa 10 à noite pois é na
teoria cada um se vira como pode